comment faire tout le monde a sa
solution il y en a qui pensent qu'il
faut se séparer puis l'homme noir pour
grand-chose qui ya personne qui
m'inspire vraiment les agit dans le
paysage actuel
je trouve que ça vaudrait le coup vu que
le canada marche pas bien non plus de
faire cinq canada un peu inspirée du
modèle des cantons suisses ou allemands
avec un prix le président du pays serait
le premier ministre des cinq régions
comme je vous dis une nouvelle france à
l'est battre alberta saskatchewan sont
des jeunes coalition l'ouest fait
longtemps qu'ils sont séparés bon pied
et puis faire comme ça que le président
soit comment comme en suisse
automatiquement pendant un an ce manteau
de battes et fait attention ce que tu me
fais l'année prochaine c'est moi qui ai
touba plus de dons s'ouvre à des
milliards en élections fédérales